i've been uh since november fourth
november third now i don't even remember
was the election november third or
november fourth
since the early november presidential
election we have covered
the goal post moves from the right
about when trump is coming back
to power and we are now hours
from the next milestone and law
enforcement is on alert
over concerns that the q anon trumpian
people
may go nuts when donald trump
obviously does not become president
tomorrow i'll tell you about that
conspiracy theory in a moment as a
reminder
um i tell me if i'm missing anything but
initially the claim was donald trump
won in early november and we will know
that when all the votes are counted
increasingly as it seemed that was not
the case the move was
we are going to file lawsuits in some
places to stop the count
in some places to keep counting even
though the ballots are all done being
counted there's no more ballots to count
and once that's done donald trump will
be announced
as the next president of the united
states november 8th came
and the media said we've seen enough
clearly joe biden is the winner
at that point the trumpian move became
sometime between now
and december 14th when the electors
actually
certify the state elections and vote
their electoral votes we will get these
results overturned
either through lawsuits or through
sending a different slate of electors or
whatever and none of that happened then
on december 14th
joe biden got his 306 electoral votes
and then they
said between december 14th and january
6th
the formal counting and acceptance of
the electoral votes in a joint session
of the house and senate
sometime in that three and a half week
period for three week period
they are going to do something which
will prevent
joe biden from officially getting those
votes on january 6th then we know how
that turned out
and then they were waiting for something
to happen between january 6th and
january 20th
and that didn't happen so the new one is
march
4th which is tomorrow there are segments
of q anon slash trump people
who believe that tomorrow march 4th
donald trump will become president again
why
because the presidential inauguration
up until 1933 was on march 4th instead
of january 20th
1933 that was changed and inauguration
day became january 20th
and the belief they have is that donald
trump is going to make a defiant and
triumphant return to the oval office
tomorrow now of course it's not going to
happen but authorities and law
enforcement are worried
and will be on high alert for tomorrow
because the chance of violence is
non-zero now they they are
saying it doesn't seem as though there's
a major risk
of violence tomorrow when donald trump
obviously does not become
president of the united states law
enforcement saying they're not seeing
large-scale physical mobilization
that suggests there will be in-person
events that a lot of it is
online and for the time being
we are being told that law enforcement
is on alert but not
expecting major violence or in-person
elements capital police of course is
monitoring it federal authorities are
exercising caution etc
there will be additional personnel
deployed around the capitol building
national guard is going to continue
supporting local officers in washington
dc
and um members of congress who uh
are willing to accept that this is
another conspiracy
conspiracy theory that's floating around
are remaining vigilant i guess is what
we are going to say
is this the end in all honesty is this
the end of these
wild conspiracy theories that donald
trump is going to take power back over
and
in a sense i think there will never be
an end and what i mean by that is as
follows
when trump doesn't become president
tomorrow they might move on to some new
date
joe biden will never make it past june 1
or something like that
eventually the date will just become the
2024 election
that that's that's my belief at this
point in time as these milestone dates
come and go
much like with these end timers who they
make a prediction and the world doesn't
end and then they say well we
you know our protractor was not aligned
properly and we miscalculated it's
actually going to be this other thing
this other thing this other thing
um eventually they'll just go go to we
are taking power back in november of
2024
when donald trump will win so if you're
expecting them to ever say
it's really over i doubt they're going
to do that i think it will just move to
the 2024 election and as an intermediate
probably even the 2022 election where
they will claim
uh they're going to take control of the
house and senate which they may
which is why it's important for us to be
more focused on the midterms
rather than on 2024 at this point in
time
a little homework for you if you're
willing if you're interested
keep an eye out for what they say
tomorrow
when trump doesn't become president send
me examples of
how they rationalize it or what they're
saying if you're on parlor maybe you can
find some interesting stuff there
right-wing news websites uh a coping
maga twitter as it's called
subreddits i'm curious and maybe we'll
make a segment out of it
when you see me sitting here at the
microphone oftentimes i'm wearing a
shirt by a company called
teddy stratford and i love these shirts
so much that i asked teddy stratford to
be a sponsor of the show
and here's why i like their shirt so
much with other slim fit button-up
shirts
you often get this weird looking gap
between the buttons where it looks kind
of stretched out but teddy stratford
actually has a patented zipper
that's hidden underneath the buttons
which secures the shirt against your
chest so it doesn't look
stretched and most importantly it just
provides a nicer looking fit overall
and the entire shirt is specially
designed to really improve the way your
upper body looks when you're wearing it
it also has a special type of collar
that prevents it from drooping down and
spreading open which is another
really great thing about these shirts
all of these things
really do a lot to make a big difference
when you're looking at a shirt
and that's why i like to wear teddy
stratford shirts on the show
go check them out at davidpakman.com
teddy the link is down below and they'll
give you 15
off your first order if you use the
coupon code pacman
at checkout